y promesas incumplidas para la devastada
isla de providencia cuando se cumple un
año del paso del huracán yo está que
dejó sin vivienda a la mayoría de sus
casi seis mil habitantes
el presidente colombiano iván duque
había prometido que el archipiélago
sería reconstruido en 100 días o menos
sin embargo un año después las promesas
distan de la realidad empezamos con lo
que denominado el plan 100 el huracán yo
está que alcanzó la categoría 5 la más
alta de todas tocó tierra en providencia
y tumbó árboles inundó viviendas desechó
casas y además destruyó la
infraestructura de comunidades dejando
la isla totalmente incomunicada con el
exterior por varios meses el proyecto
del gobierno planeaba construir 80
viviendas cada mes para una entrega
total de
1.787 casas hasta el momento se han
entregado a 962 es decir tan sólo 54 por
ciento de lo prometido y por lo menos 69
familias llevan más de 11 meses
durmiendo en carpas que se inundan
cuando llueve no puedo decir porque el
señor alcalde quien es autónomo en esa
decisión totalmente autónomo ya lo dijo
él considera que la isla va a estar
lista para abrirla en la semana santa
en cuanto a establecimientos comerciales
identificaron 54 con necesidades de
reparación pero tan solo el pasado mes
de octubre empezaron las obras en cinco
de ellos y aunque las autoridades
planean la apertura de providencia como
paraíso turístico del caribe para marzo
de 2022 todavía queda por fuera el
proyecto de construcción del hospital
más grande de la isla para atender a los
afectados por el kobe 19 que por ahora
se atienden en hospitales de campaña
transitorios así como la construcción de
la red de acueducto y alcantarillado los
cuales requieren una inversión
estructural mayor